hello there i'm gav if you're sensitive
to flickering imagery i'd give this
video a miss because it's horrendous
over the past couple of decades of
filming hundreds of subjects in slo-mo
i've become most fascinated with the
stuff that sits right in front of our
eyes yeah is a total lie and a great
example of that i found is all of the
different types of displays that we
spend our lives staring at there have
been many different types of displays
used over the years that look relatively
similar to the human eye but using the
power of super slow-mo we can see that
they all work in incredibly different
ways in previous videos i've shown you
that lcd plasma and oled displays use
raster scanning where they basically
have a grid of pixels which is
progressively scanned from top to bottom
each line shoots across the screen from
left to right and it quickly builds the
frame from top to bottom to the point
where you can see the entire completed
frame even in slo-mo this works very
similarly to a crt screen which uses an
electron gun that steers across the
screen building the image
line by line all the way down to the
bottom before starting again on the next
frame and there's a short blanking
interval where the beam can move without
drawing anything on the screen if it
needs to start a new line or if it needs
to reset back to the top for the next
frame the way a crt differs from a
modern display is that there's no
complete image
left on the screen you're really only
dealing with that one area where the
electron beam is currently hitting the
phosphors on the front of the screen
it's just your persistence of vision
your brain
completes the image just because it
can't see quick enough to see that
there's only just a small dot lit up if
you ever take a photo of a crt tv it's
very unlikely you'll end up with a
complete image just because the decay is
so fast you'll end up with a partial
image based on the duration of the
exposure on your photo so that leads us
to the next step in our journey through
fascinating display technologies this
thing i feel like tech mode but without
the mancunian charm this is tempest a
1981
arcade game that i'm terrible at that
uses vector graphics this is still a crt
display
hence the flickering you're seeing on
the screen right now but the way it
draws each frame
is completely different this was known
as atari's color quadrascan vector
display there were other games at the
time that used vector graphics such as
asteroids which typically was just one
color this was capable of multiple
colors the electron beam is basically
allowed to arbitrarily move all around
the screen drawing lines between
different coordinates it can control the
color and it can control the brightness
so if it set its brightness to zero it
was able to move and start in a new area
of the screen without drawing the line
and there's actually little hints on the
screen where you can see because it's
quite an old game
it's not really capable of dimming all
the way down so you can kind of see
little trails where the beam has moved
from one place to the other similarly to
all the other displays that we look at
this happens way too fast for our eyes
to see so why don't we show this thing
in all of its glory by whipping out a
very fast phantom and shooting it at
absurd frame rates i'll start off by
shooting at 28 500 frames a second on
the v2511 kindly provided by destin
[Music]
this is what it looks like a thousand as
you can see i definitely needed a faster
camera for this one
here we are at 28 500 frames a second
the game isn't drawn from the top to the
bottom or in any specific area first
there are just different passes made for
different elements of the game i'm not
going to play that clip again but in
post i'm going to hold the brightest
points of the clip this is effectively
what our eyes and brain end up with when
looking at it in real life
that entire frame was completed in just
18 milliseconds
so as you can see it starts with the
score then draws in the lives a little
bit more text at the top then it starts
working on the walls of the course then
the yellow lines signify where your
little blaster is currently situated
then it does the back opening the front
opening followed by you then it starts
doing all of the particles and enemies
and shots and explosions inside the map
to give the illusion of a much bigger
shape or a filled in shape it can just
keep drawing lines over the same spot
but in reality the entire screen is made
up of lines and dots after all that it
starts working on the next frame where
chances are a lot of the elements on the
screen are now in a different place
here are some glimpses of some other
games this is
battlezone which i showed earlier and
also
this one is star wars
all the gameplay and all the text once
again made up of only lines
while i was at this arcade i thought
it'd be interesting to show multiple
machines next to each other you can see
here the smash tv and the super mario
brothers machines both drawing their
images from top to bottom regardless of
gameplay elements and then you've got
tempest in the middle just drawing
whatever it feels like
to the eye unless you already know about
these two different technologies i think
it's very difficult to tell which
displays machines are using chances are
if it's just line art it's vector and
vector maybe looks slightly more
flickery to the eye especially when
there's lots of lines being included in
the same frame of gameplay there are
definitely pros and cons to this type of
display the upsides are the graphics
look incredibly crisp and high
resolution especially for the time and
it's not a crushed looking sprite trying
to fit into a small grid as it's scaled
up and down and rotated and stuff like
that and the main downside of these
displays is that anything on them is
just hollow shapes and lines it's not
possible to fill in any of the shapes
with solid colors or anything like that
so there is that limitation well there
we have it hopefully you found that
footage as fascinating as i did i'm
always just so intrigued to learn about
how old technology worked especially
when you need a high speed camera to see
it it's just
insane when you think about it really if
you think you know someone who might
enjoy this video feel free to send to
them make sure you subscribe and now i'm
going to pass it over to me to talk
about simply safe take it away me thanks
me simply safe is currently in the
middle of their big holiday deal with 40
or more off let me tell you a little bit
about their service simply safe is an
immensely customizable security system
allowing you to design a system with the
best fit for your place straight to your
door there are centers to cover every
window room and door as well as hd
cameras for indoors and outdoors the
ultra wide 140 degree field of view
really hits that sweet spot for coverage
around your property once all that is in
place your home is professionally
monitored 24 7 by simply safe's team
i've relied pretty heavily on security
systems in my past i think it's
incredibly important for everyone to
have something in place but not only
that it can also come in very handy if
you start spontaneously pranking your
friend and you don't have time to set up
a regular camera what
i just dropped that
we're just walking along i just dropped
that if you haven't seen the video where
i pranked dan
give it a watch after this it's a good
one one of my favorite aspects of the
simply safe system is that everything is
under the same ecosystem so you're not
worrying about a camera from one company
a door lock from another everything is
controlled by the base station
everything communicates very well with
everything else because of that it's
incredibly simple to set everything up
it's very fast if that sounds like
something you might be interested in you
can save 40 percent or more by going to
simplysafe.com
slomo guys thank you very much for
watching and i'll see you next time